decapitation it's pretty simple it's the
total separation of the head from the
body
this includes a complete severing of 26
muscles
four major blood vessels the spinal
column and most importantly
the spinal cord which by the way
regulates a multitude of motor
sensory and autonomic functions in
contrast
internal decapitations only involve the
separation of the spinal cord from the
base of the skull
but the neck is still attached to the
body the exact cause of death in a
decapitation
is technically severing of the spinal
cord and rapid blood loss
and that's all there is to know about
the anatomy of decapitation
however i'm willing to bet you clicked
on this video with something else in
mind
not just how you die from a decapitation
but also if your severed head is still
conscious
well that's what the rest of the video
covers and by referencing scientific
experiments and reliable data there
certainly is an answer
but first a shout out to the sponsor of
this video babel
if you're watching this then chances are
you're not decapitated which means your
brain is still working just fine but you
know what they say
if you don't use it you lose it and
that's where babel comes in babel is the
number one language learning app in the
world with over 14 different
languages a 2012 study from the dana
foundation
showed that being bilingual helped
participants process information more
efficiently
improved memory and enhanced visual
spatial skills or
maybe you're like me and you're
traveling abroad so you have to learn a
new language in a pinch
babel can teach you a new language in
just three weeks with 10 to 15 minute
lessons a day
you'll go from sounding like this excuse
me server
waiter anybody to this
excuse me in fact studies have shown
that 15 hours of babble is commensurate
with the semester of college spanish
classes are constructed by 150 real
language teachers
giving you real words and phrases you'll
actually use in addition to traditional
learning
babel offers different methods of
learning as well such as podcasts
interactive games and more
babble has a very special offer of 65
off
click the link in the description for
more information a deal this good
is a no-brainer the question of
consciousness after decapitation
is one people have wondered for
centuries considering that the visual
auditory scent and even touched senses
in the brain are not directly affected
by decapitation
it's theoretically possible for
consciousness to remain intact
oh by the way severed heads cannot talk
i didn't mean to scare you because
there's no vocal cords attached
anyways only the brain stem is directly
affected in decapitation
so with these regions being untouched it
could lend possible consciousness
historically the most famous alleged
instance of consciousness
after decapitation was the execution of
charlotte corday
during the french revolution corday had
murdered french journalist and
politician
jean-paul marat she was tried found
guilty
and sentenced to public execution by the
guillotine
after she was decapitated the
executioner's assistant francois legro
lifted her head for the crowd to see and
slapped it
eyewitnesses claimed they saw cordee's
face blush
and show a look of anger at legro but
eyewitness accounts are not reliable
data
especially as scientific data what the
crowd believed to be consciousness was
likely reflexive facial nerves firing
away in a severed head
however post-decapitation facial
movements historically have been cited
as
proof of consciousness but these only
exist in non-scientific historical
records and are more folklore than
anything else
however history is not completely void
in this case
there was one scientific experiment
known to observe
human consciousness after decapitation
in 1905.
french physician dr gabriel barrow was
given permission to conduct experiments
on a prisoner
set for execution the prisoner henry
langu was executed on june 28
1905 for murder the guillotine dropped
and langu's head
fell dr barrow grabbed the severed head
immediately to begin the experiment
holding langu's severed head he began to
speak to it
the following is what he recorded in his
medical journal
i was able to note immediately after the
decapitation the eyelids and lips of the
guillotine man
worked in irregularly rhythmic
contractions for about five or six
seconds
the spasmodic movement ceased it was
then i called in a strong sharp voice
langu i saw the eyelids slowly lift up
without any spasmodic contractions i
insist
quite distinct and normal such as
happens in everyday life
with people awakened or torn from their
thoughts dr barreaux repeated this two
more times
and allege the head responded each time
though it sounds astounding
no observations have ever been
referenced from other physicians or
scientists nor has the experiment been
published in an accredited medical
journal
language reactions were likely delayed
reflexes
or barrow may have over exaggerated his
observations out of excitement
but this only generates more questions
than it does answers
what is the baseline for consciousness
does the severed head have to be
blinking or show
facial or mouth movements to be
conscious what if what appears to be an
expressionless severed head
is actually a being with full
consciousness this question was tested
by a team of dutch and french scientists
in 2011. in the study decapitation in
rats
latency to unconsciousness and the wave
of death the electrical activity of rap
brains was measured using an eeg
or electroencephalography both before
and after decapitation
ideally the readings would show normal
electrical activity then decapitation
followed by either continued electrical
output or none at all
the eeg is the best measurement of
consciousness after decapitation
because if there's no electrical
activity in the brain
i.e no neurons firing how can you be
conscious and aware
two groups of rats were used one group
was conscious before decapitation
and the other was made unconscious using
anesthetics
since the unconscious group would be
producing unconscious brain waves before
decapitation the scientists could use
this to compare to the post-decapitation
brain waves to determine if they were
truly conscious
or unconscious here are the results
there's many graphs and tables from the
experiment and i could go through every
single
one and bore you on all the details but
no the only graph that really matters to
us
is this one right here the red dots and
lines signify the unconscious or
anesthetized wraths and the blue lines
and dot signifies the conscious or awake
rats immediately after decapitation
which is this dotted line right here the
electrical activity in the brain drops
very quickly within 10 seconds similar
to a battery that loses its charge
when the brain loses electrical activity
it cannot power
all of its different functions one of
these functions being
sensory input according to the eeg the
cognitive activity in the wrap brain
that maintains
sensory input such as sight smell
hearing and pain
dropped below 50 3.7 seconds
after decapitation a decrease of 50
percent
in cognitive activity means the rat's
brain cannot maintain consciousness
this means that during those 3.7 seconds
after decapitation
sensory input continued and therefore
there was consciousness
however after four seconds consciousness
was completely lost
and within 20 seconds the brain produced
zero electrical activity
which can be seen as a flat line on this
eeg reading
there you have it what turned out to be
gory folklore turned out to be
gory reality if you ever find yourself
beneath the guillotine or an
executioner's axe
be sure to take a good look around
because afterwards those three or four
seconds are going to be your last